the bright young star of Batman Forever
and
scent of a woman Chris O'Donnell
70 years ago Warner Brothers started a
revolution in entertainment they made a
motion a movie picture that actually
talked it was the jazz singer and it
starred the legendary Al Jolson after
singing one song Jolson spoke the line
that became the legend you ain't heard
nothing yet Jolson's words were truer
than he realized from those first
scratchy soundtracks to all the films
nominated for this year's awards our
engineers have improved sound to a point
where you can hear everything in today's
movies for best achievement and sound
the nominees are Walter Murch mark
Berger David Parker and Chris Newman for
the English Patient Andy Nelson
Annabelle mer and Ken Westin for Evita
Chris Carpenter bill W Benton Bob BEMER
and Jeff Wexler for Independence Day
Kevin O'Connell Greg P Russell and Keith
a Westar for the rock
Steve Maslow Greg land acre Kevin
O'Connell and Jeffery Patterson for
twister
and the Oscar goes to
Walter Murch mark Berger David Parker
and Chris Newman for the English Patient
thank you to everyone at the souls aunts
Film Center for their technical and
artistic support thank you to Pat
Jackson for great sound effects thank
you to Saul Zaentz and Anthony Minghella
a collaborative and compassionate
director thank you to my wife Aggie
thank you I'd also like to thank our
scintillating Lee effervescent sound
editor Pat Jackson and my wife Susan and
particularly the Academy for honoring a
film that could be as exciting and
engaging in its quiet moments as in his
loud ones thanks for listening thanks
for the Academy psalm Anthony everyone
who worked on the sound of the film into
Stephanie Amanda and Molly thank you
very much